قتيل ودمار بهجوم عنيف شنه مستوطنون على
قريه قرب رام الله
يصف نظره الصيني بالديكتاتور وبكين تارود
وقصه مغامر انسحب في اللحظه الاخيره من
رحله الغواصه المفقوده
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
ونبدا من فلسطين حيث شنع عشرات المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين هجوما عنيفا على بلده ترمس
عياش شمال رام الله وقرى الاخرى في حواره
قرب نابلس وابرم النيران في اراضي زراعيه
ومنازل ومتاجر ومركبات للفلسطينيين رئيس
بلديه ترمس عيا اكد ان نحو 400 مستوطنين
اقتحموا البلده واحرقوا اكثر من 30 منزلا
ونحو 60 سياره كما اطلقوا الرصاص الحي
تجاه المواطنين فيما ادت مواجهات مع الجيش
الاسرائيلي في المكان الى مقتل فلسطيني
واصابه العشرات بجروح متفاوته
في السودان انفجرت الاوضاع في البلاد على
اكثر من جبهه مع انتهاء الهدنه الهشه حيث
اندلعت اشتباكات عنيفه في مدينه الدلنج
بولايه جنوب كردفان بين الجيش وقوات
الحركه الشعبيه بقياده عبد العزيز الحلو
وزير الصحه بولايه شمال كردفان قال ان
القتال بين الجيش والدعم السريع تسبب في
مقتل واصابه مئات الاشخاص في الولايه منذ
اندلاع الحرب فيما شهدت الاجواء في البلاد
طلعات جويه للطيران الحربي في ام درمان
وفي الخرطوم بينما تصدت لها قوات الدعم
السريع بالمضادات الارضيه
وصف الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن نظيره
الصيني
بينما كان يتحدث خلال حفل لجمع التبرعات
للحزب الديمقراطي بحضور الصحافه تصريحات
بايدن اتت بعد يومين فقط من زياره قصيره
قام بها وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني
بلينكن الى الصين والتقى خلالها بالرئيس
الصين فيما ردت بكين على لسان الناطقه
باسم الخارجيه الصينيه بالقول ان وصفه
بايدن ينتهك بشده الكرامه السياسيه للصين
ويصل الى حد الاستفزاز السياسي العلني
مشيره الى ان الصين مستاءه بشده وترفض
تماما هذه التصريحات
ما زالت قصه الغواصه المختفيه في اعماق
المحيط الاطلسي تتصدر التراند وعناوين
الاخبار الجديد هذه المره هو انسحاب مغامر
بريطاني في اللحظات الاخيره قبل انطلاق
الرحله بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالسلامه
ذواحد وستين عاما قال لصحيفه
ان عمليه صناعه الغواصه تمت بسرعه كبيره
وهذا يعني استهتارا كبيرا بالسلامه على حد
وصفه مشيرا ايضا الى انه اكتشف استخدام
دعامات قديمه لخزانات الماء المسؤوله عن
توازن الغواصه
وفي خبرنا الاخير دخلت جامعه كيوتو
اليابانيه في شراكه مع شركات عده لاطلاق
اول قمر صناعي خشبي في العالم سيتم بناؤه
باستخدام تقنيات النجاره اليابانيه
التقليديه تقارير افادت بانه من المقرر
انطلاق هذا القمر من الولايات المتحده في
مارس 2024 مشيره الى ان وكاله ناسا
والوكاله اليابانيه لاستكشاف في الفضاء
تخططان لاجراء فحص سلامه نهائي في اكتوبر
المقبل قبل عمليه الاطلاق اما الهدف من
صناعه هذا القمر فهو تقليل الانبعاثات
الضاره الناتجه عن احتراق الاقمار العاديه
وبالتالي الحفاظ على البيئه